episode 6 is very very important for our
characters quite epiphonic for Valentina
what about you wasn't it let me panic of
course of course she likes you you know
you just like me
oh Mia once it's just to play that piano
like she knows that maybe if she
manipulates you into that then she'll
get it
you think that you manipulate me I don't
know if you manipulate me or if you are
sincere Valentino doesn't feel seen by
people that's why it was like
heartbreaking that Isabella was with
Rocco Rocco
Victoria
and in fact Valentina breaks down and in
that moment
to like finish a ride
exactly
isn't it so interesting that this
Dynamic that you give me something I
give you something it's known as a male
female Dynamic and there is this dynamic
between two women
for Valentina to live what she lived in
episode 6. it's something that is going
to change her life forever I think that
probably Valentina finally accepts the
idea that a new life could be possible
for her the funny thing about our two
characters that we start off I am
innocent and she's very explosive and
then eventually we switch it's an
interesting material all the characters
are really tragic in a way but they're
really funny it's just exciting to play
a character like this
[Music]
Tanya absolutely
she's the best but she's hard work okay
okay I think I would pick an easy person
maybe I'll go with with Alby you know
he's okay with everything
[Music]
when I'm traveling I like to drink when
I get there otherwise I just feel sick
maybe on the way
maybe I could drink during the flight
yes a good a good glass of red wine yes
I don't have limits in my desire of
traveling beaches mountains cities I
would go everywhere I think I love
mountains I love everything but I love
mountains
oh my God me when I go on vacation I'm
totally wild my ideal vacation is
following smells and sounds so me I love
to arrive in a place and the first smell
I like I follow the smell I am so
disorganized so I think I can't plan
anything so when I travel I just just go
with the flow
[Music]
foreign